did you know the terraform uses a few
simple commands to transform your HDL
code into infrastructure resources in
this short we'll cover basic terraform
commands and their functionalities at a
high level
the three most important and frequently
used commands in terraform are
terraformin is terraform plan and
terraform apply
the first command to run is terraform
init it's used to initialize terraform
to download the provider plugins the
state and the modules
terraform plan creates an execution plan
that details the resources that will be
created modified or destroyed after
executing the terraform apply command
think of this command as a rehearsal
before the actual show
terraform apply executes the actions
proposed in a terraform plan creates the
resources and establishes the
dependencies
are you ready to learn more click on the
three dots and then click on the link in
the description box to enroll in the
getting started with terraform for
Google Cloud course see you there